when we send some role models to others
purpose is connected
will always be cheaper to outsource to
contractors
and outsource to people who you have the
ability
to hire and fire if you're down
the most important working to be doing
is the ones that you do feel connection
enthusiasm meaning fulfillment
satisfaction from
need motivation watch the top 10 of
believe nation because i love it
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you
are probably the most ambitious person
in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best brendon burchard and my
take on his top 10 rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one adopt
a quit rule here's what the 45
day quit rule is and it's hard for me i
hate this one
i look at all my big project ideas you
know i don't know about you but i have a
journal with
all my big ideas in it you know or my
vision board
or i have an excel spreadsheet of all
these different ideas and projects i
want to do
and i've got like you know right as an
example right now
i know my next six books i'm going to
write
i know i know my next three campaigns
i'm gonna launch
i know them but here's what i have to
force myself to do and i don't like it
i say okay if this is a major project
that i want to do
even if it could lead to significant
growth
if i'm not going to start it listen to
this if i'm not going to start it
in the next 45 days
it's off my plate until next year and
i push it to 2019. i literally just take
it from my journal
in my little bucket of things i want to
do this year and i put it out
into 2019 and i feel so
mentally relieved a lot of people have a
lot of anxiety
about the number of projects they have
on their plate
that they really want to do and so what
ends up happening is
that anxiety leads to a lot of
procrastination
that anxiety leads to a lot of poor
prioritization because there's so much
to do
they're like oh my god there's so much
to do here so i won't do any of it
ever had that have you ever found
yourself in front of netflix
going oh my god i have so much to do but
i just watched
the fourth video in the third season has
that ever happened
you have so much to and that's the
problem you have so much to do that you
haven't prioritized what you are going
to do
so you don't do anything
so what i do is this time of year i look
at all those things that are on my plate
and i get honest which ones am i going
to start in the next 45 days
and if i'm not going to start the next
45 day put it in 2019.
now it's not even on my mental concern
it's not on my dashboard
no anxiety there no my god i still got
to get that one in nope
it's gone that's the 45 day quit rule
i encourage you to challenge yourself to
try it rule number two
step into the role you need to know what
moves the needle in your business and
hire to that
not just what you like you need to know
what skills are necessary for your
future and develop that
not just what you're naturally good at
and this is where people fail all the
time
they're just trying to play in their own
lane but once you step into the role
of a business owner or you step into the
role of leader
it's no longer about just your passions
you have a responsibility it's called
stewardship
you have stewardship to your team to
their mortgages to their rent
you have stewardship to your company now
you have stewardship to the future
you really have to step into the
identity of ceo
even if that's not what you're about but
i've
learned so long working with
entrepreneurs some of them just never
step
into the identity they need to assume to
win
they never stepped into i'm the ceo now
i'm in charge so they're kind of half
asset they're kind of like
hobby it they're not really in that role
where they've defined
this is who i am i'm in charge of
building this if i don't it all falls
apart
and take it upon themselves to say i
have to lead here well
i have to do well here because if they
don't do that
guess what no one's else is going to do
it for them rule number three
maintain a steady rhythm if you know
your person of excellence and if it's
true i would not see a rhythm of
crashing and burning
i would not see a rhythm of burns and
busts
burning out failures and exhaustion
and it's really hard because i know
trust me i
like there's so many nights i'm like oh
my god if i just stay
awake for four more hours i can get
these projects done
and you know what and then i'm a
complete idiot 72 hours later
i know it will catch up with me those
who play the long game don't compromise
in the short game
because they know it catches up later
and that ketchup is a devil
it is a bear it is a beast it knocks you
down and what happens is you i'll
compromise three hours here
but then because that compromise three
hours here
you're knocked off your feet three days
over here
so if you'd taken the three hours to
recharge
you wouldn't be worthless for three days
in the middle of the week
right i want you to have steady rhythm
that's what we call high performance
that ability of long-term success while
maintaining your well-being
and your health my friends you so
deserve that rule number four
connect to your purpose double down on
your goodness
you want to have an exceptional and
incredible 20 20 you want to find
purpose this year
double down on your goodness adopt the
role model mindset and say
how can i be a role model how can i
serve how can i do more good in the
world because as i do more good in the
world
i lift the world as i do more good in
the world it challenges me
to be a person of potential and as i
challenge myself to be a person of
potential
and i inspire other people i feel like i
am
serving a purpose see when we send some
role models to others
purpose is connected in that very moment
when you know you're being a role model
your kids
boom purpose is connected when you know
you're being a role model for your team
boom purpose is connected when you're
standing on stage and you're speaking
your truth boom
purpose is connected you don't have to
go hope to find it
it's connected when you are being
a role model it's connected when you are
activating your full potential
it's connected when you are in alignment
with your truth
you got it you have to go look for it
you need to connect to it
my friend evan carmichael's book listen
humans are built to serve
some people are built to serve the world
others
want to serve the 25 people closest to
them but in either case humans are built
to serve so if you're not happy right
now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
rule number five develop skills what are
the skills you have to develop
for me that was video for me that was
online marketing including building web
pages starting newsletters sending out
newsletters
building opt-in pages to capture name in
emails following up with sequences
automated marketing sequences i had to
learn how to do that i had to learn how
to do webinars and all these other
things not because i wanted to but i
thought
am i always going to do webinars in my
business probably better learn how to do
them
not because i had a passion for it i was
like i'm always going to do them so let
me figure it out first
try it out first do some research
there's plenty of things online
that will help me figure that out and
then after that
then i can go into hiring somebody else
because i can manage it
so first piece develop the skills
needed to win and if you don't know what
those skills are
or those skills don't currently exist in
your calendar meaning you're developing
them then
then you're just going through the
motions you're weighing it and frankly
you're risking your career
um one of my favorite things to do to
check to see if i got a high performer
in the midst when i talk with people i
go what are the three skills you're
working on right now in developing
and if they don't know it i know they're
amateurs that's just it
there's amateurs they're beginners and
that's not to judge them that's just to
say they haven't stepped into
living what we call the high performance
experience the high performance
experience is all about developmental
goals it's all
about bringing our best and growing into
what we need to rule number six
journal and review your daily g3 journal
and review uh if you've heard me teach a
lot about
down times before uh especially the last
couple
years a couple years ago the the g3 was
the three g's
and it's what it means is every single
day i want you to journal on these three
things and i do mean journal meaning you
write it down
in the morning and you review it at
night
so you that's why it says journal and
review so you write in the morning
and review it all at night and so here's
what the g3 is the first thing you know
is your gratitude and that is just what
are you grateful for
why does that make you feel good why are
you thankful for it
and just write it down in your journal
just a whole like you should have a
gratitude journal already
but when you're disappointed or having
setbacks i want you to do the gratitude
in the morning
a lot of graduate journal stuff is that
tonight i want you to move it right up
the morning like just
you got to prime your morning for some
goodness so right off the bat
you got to do that okay so gratitude
second major thing i want you to focus
on
is your goals where the specific daily
and weekly goals you're working on
you got to get really narrow focused
right when you're disappointed or sad or
setback
uh you know the idea of creating a
vision board
and seeing out 10 years from now that's
too much what you need to do
is get really close in your term this
day's goals
this week's goals because if you can
check those suckers off
and get a little progress in you'll feel
differently as we talk about
so goals is important and the third g
is goodness and the goodness is
noticing what is good from the previous
day
so when you start the day you're like
okay what am i grateful for in general
for life what are my goals specifically
daily and weekly
in each of these different areas of my
life you might have goals in your career
and your health and your finances and
your relationships
and then the goodness is what actually
good did happen
yesterday and that will just get you in
a place where you're like oh
this day is going to be good too it's
making you more mindful to all the good
things and the reason i do that one
last and the difference between
gratitude gratitude is general things
you're grateful for
the goodness thing is to think about
what good happened yesterday
and the reason we do that because in
neuroscience we know that thinking about
the goodness from yesterday
is triggering your hippocampus to kind
of turn on and fire up
and if we get more memory activation off
the bat
in the morning we actually have more
creativity in the day too
it's weird sparking memory is good for
creativity
creativity is very good for coping and
so that's why i'm trying to get you to
reflect a little bit
on something that happened yesterday
just to think through find that mindful
moment
and it's also teaching you to be more
mindful as through of the moments each
day
not just grateful in general but
actually being mindful for the good
moments
each day so i want you to do that
journal every morning and then
every night i want you to look back at
it
and think about it and maybe repeat it
if you want to
i just want you to review the day and
review those things what was i grateful
for oh yeah that's right
because maybe at the end of the day the
truth is you haven't moved a lot forward
maybe you know your your spouse or
yourself you're still sick
or maybe there's still conflict or maybe
the business because
i'm not going to be pollyannish and say
everything changes in one day and
everything's great just because you did
your gratitude journal
you might do that today it still sucks
so reviewing it
is going to put you back in that
positive mindset that's going to help
you
then take the next day as well rule
number seven
outsource before you hire a team i
really encourage you
to either hire one person and the two of
you outsource a lot of the tasks
so you learn what that looks like
because if you haven't outsourced tasks
before
you're gonna be a pretty crappy manager
or leader
right if you just go i'm gonna hire a
bunch of people and you get them on
board but you've never actually
managed task assignment and task
completion
it gets really hard so what i tell most
people if you're just starting which i
know many of you
were in your brands or businesses or
many of you are solopreneurs
and you asked me about this and he said
brandon what if i'm just hiring my first
two people what would you do
i see my first two people i might first
understand your skill sets
i might hire somebody to be your virtual
assistant
or somebody to plug one specific skill
set hole that you just don't have
but then the two of you before you hire
number three four five and six i
actually want the two of you or yourself
to outsource first go to like upwork go
to fiverr go to something where you can
put out tasks as projects to people and
manage that
see how that feels see if you like that
see if you find yourself going i i don't
really like working with other people
some of you should never work with
another human being you're just you're
horrible
you just should you should just know
that about yourself and accept that
about yourself
step into that truth if you don't want
to lead or be around people
you know what you'll find that out
pretty soon as you start outsourcing
i really encourage you in other words
i'm
sort of imploring you take baby steps
baby steps into hiring just baby steps
it
it's like when you go to college and
business school they're just like well
start with hiring your team and defining
your culture and having a mission
statement and values
and i'm like that's even fast for most
people the worst thing someone can do is
go hire five people and not even know if
they
know what their business is what their
skills should be or if they
like assigning delegating and following
up on tasks
so first outsource and in general most
of
the repetitive or simple tasks that you
have in your business
you should look for ways to outsource
that first
before you hire internally why it's
just straight up basics of math
it will always be cheaper to outsource
to contractors
and outsource to people who you have the
ability
to hire and fire immediately because
they're work for hire
versus it's somebody who's on your
payroll who who's a team
member who you have to give you know
three warnings to before you let them go
and especially if you're just starting
and you don't really know what the
rhythm
there is going to be for them to work
with you outsourcing is great
it helps you find your tempo it helps
you find what you really do as a
business
to outsource so i'd love for you to just
think about and you haven't done this
and you own your business or you lead a
team
to sit down and go okay what are all the
repetitive tasks that happen in my
business rule number eight
synthesize and edit down noise
let me review where my week went good
and bad and
let me decouple my emotions from that so
i can
enter monday with freedom because when i
am in a space of freedom
i make much better decisions than when i
am in the space
of lack when i am in the space of
self-hatred when i'm in the space of
carrying all this stuff
unprocessed i mean have we learned
anything
from personal development other than hey
you got to process the stuff that went
that happened in your life and
understand how you identify with that
and what you're going to do next you got
to process it man and most people
because they're not processing their
immediate snap judgments of self
oh i screwed up imagine if we could just
loop back your last couple months
and every single week just think about
every think about how much you screwed
up the last couple months i don't know
about you but mine's like a
like like my hands would have to like i
can't i don't have enough hands
like to count the number of screw-ups in
the last couple months i can't
it's like it's so infinite number of
screw-ups but imagine if every time i
screw up i'm like oh you're screw up
ugh you're dumb brendan and my self-talk
in that moment was snap judgment
which most people it is snap judging
self-talk
dummy oh i know this stupid brendan
imagine if we take a loop of that for
the last six months
uninterrupted unpaused unedited
and we took out all the situations of
life we removed all context
and it just sounded like screw up you
suck you suck you suck why'd you do that
oh my god dummy dummy dummy stupid
stupid stupid stupid
and we didn't de-hook that
we didn't decouple that that's what most
people's realities are
and because that's always running
unconsciously
because they're not deliberate about
processing they're not living a
courageous life now
because every time they think of
courageous thought that overwhelming
chorus of noise filters
and swamps and smashes
that that whisper of a dream that is
bold
is beaten to death by the rap base
of the horrid talk that we have with
each other it's like
right and so that noise
needs to be synthesized
and edited down on a simple sunday
you just sit there on your sunday and
you go all right man
i had a lot of noise this last week
a lot of things didn't go the way i did
but you know what let me think about
them
how could i have met those situations as
my highest self
or more courage yourself what could i
have done okay good
good brendan you're learning good job
brennan you're learning oh yeah you
could have been better then
yeah good for you having the intention
to be better good for you to learn
brendan
good for you to set higher intentions
brennan good job being on purpose good
job brendan
trying to improve your life okay good
job you really
you got a new way to look at that
brennan good job now just
let it go man just take that emotion
and let that emotion float away for a
little bit
don't let that emotion from that mess up
mess up my monday it's sunday
i gotta let that go i forgive myself
from that situation
because i've learned i forgive the other
people in the situation
because even if they didn't learn i
learned and they gave me a lesson
i let go of that situation because that
situation is not in this moment as i'm
sitting
here with my green tea and my journal
reflecting on last week
in this moment i got a journal i got a
green tea it's just me
and the green tea so you see we've got
this opportunity
to make a space every week
in which we debrief the weak
and decouple ourselves unhitch
the trailer of weight and let it fall
back down the hill
rule number nine progress towards
meaning if i'm having
some dark days and sad times i'm like i
got to get progress
so what i'll do is i'll identify my five
major moves if
you read this book high performance
habits you know about the five major
moves so identify my five major moves
and i'm like i'll swiftly move towards
one
because momentum can shift mindset
and so if i'm in a dark disappointment
down momentum
like achieve some goals but here's
what's important notice i said the five
major moves that's what i mean with
progress
because what a lot of people mistakenly
do is they just start doing lots of
tasks and activities
that aren't correlated in any way to the
meaningful pursuits of life
so here's what happened i'm bummed i'm
down
so i'm doing a bunch of work the next
day they still
feel bummed and down because what was
their work it was a bunch of activities
that actually didn't matter
they didn't give them any meaning so if
you're down
the most important working you'll be
doing is the ones that you do feel
connection
enthusiasm meaning fulfillment
satisfaction from
those ones that do intrinsically bring
you joy
those are the ones that i want you to
progress towards matter of fact
i really want you when you're feeling
down disappointed major setbacks dark
days
what i really desperately want you to do
is stop multitasking
and doing all the little like busy work
things that don't matter
like like put off like
if if it's wednesday and you know you
got a stack of bills
and they're not due for another
30 days don't pay the bills that day
because that's not fun and you're you've
got plenty of time to do it later when
you fee
like when you get over this piece this
funk like just say
okay write the date on those bills pay
them on but don't do it today
because that's busy work instead today
find an activity that you find to be
creative compelling engaging fulfilling
and do that progress towards the things
that have
meaning that's huge when you're down
but most people don't do that because
what's comforting just like eating
comfort food
is doing low hanging fruit activity
i'll pay the bills and answer a bunch of
emails you know but those small little
tasks
those don't give you enough bang for the
buck to really move through it
and there's a big misconception about
that in the culture
including the science that often says oh
no no just you know if people can
complete small steps small tasks they'll
feel
better and it's like well yeah
i mean we all have this reward system in
our brain and a little dopamine will
fall out
but do we do we want a little drip drip
of dopamine
or do we want the floodgates to come
open and feel alive
so i want you to do the activities that
are more meaningful
not just like tasks you know
it's really important and rule number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus clips
is create meaningful moments you've got
to start creating meaningful moments
in your life what do you mean by that
well listen
you and i both don't i mean how many
times you get caught up in the day you
get caught up in the news you caught up
on you you're you know swiping and
looking and looking and consuming you
get caught up in your to-do list you get
caught up in all the emails you get
caught up in all the work
and all of a sudden the whole day went
by and you didn't feel it
and i'm here to tell you something that
really remarkable that i've learned this
last year
uh you know last year was my first year
where as a high performance coach i was
coaching two billionaires
and i've never done that before i mean i
mean many of you guys know and you've
been with me on my journey
you know for what uh two decades i've
been in personal development and in this
last decade it's kind of where i made my
mark you know i
published six books uh we grew our
audience to you know whatever five
million on facebook and
you know eight hundred thousand whatever
it is on instagram now eight hundred
thousand on youtube
uh best-selling books traveling you've
seen us fill the rooms and all the
events that i do
but this last year was like a whole
other level for me it was so hard
so challenging we we moved denise and i
and i also started taking on these
caliber of clients i mean holy cow i
didn't know
i didn't know if i could handle it i
mean i'm not a billionaire
i got no problem telling anybody that
i'm not out there trying to pretend i
you know pretend uh you can't fake it
with
billionaires they know and so when i was
coaching them
i kind of struggled for a while to
figure out what they were unhappy about
i hope that doesn't sound flippant but i
was like wow they got so much going for
what what's up why why aren't you
happier if you have
everything right like the material
things most people are seeking why
aren't you happier
and i'll ask you guys that same thing
why do you feel like you're not happier
like what's going on i mean
most people consumer watching this i
mean
you're doing okay i mean you might be
unhappy
here and there you you might struggle
with like especially i mean
a tremendous amount of our audience in
personal development is strivers they're
achievers they're working hard they're
often the leaders in their community and
everyone goes wow
they're already impressed with you
they're already happy that you're
chasing your dream they're already like
kind of you like you're living your own
you're living life on your own terms a
little bit and so were these major
people i was
coaching i couldn't figure out what's
going on with them and then i finally i
tripped on it
maybe it was last year the end of i
think was the end of the prior year
i got it here they were doing amazing
things guys
every single day they were living the
dream
they had finances they they had impact
they you know people were impressed with
them they
uh you know had love often in their life
they were married or had
good kids or whatever but they still
weren't happy
and they still did not feel connected
and
here is what i discovered they did not
feel the day
say it again they didn't feel
the day they went through the day some
of them very high achieving through the
day
accomplishing things on their purpose
making a difference a role model earning
doing the whole thing
and yet when they laid their head on the
pill at night they hadn't felt
the day think about that for a moment
think about how many days you go to bed
and you didn't really
feel the moments of the day
and this is why too many days unfelt
leads to a disconnect with purpose
too many days unfelt leads to a
disconnect
with purpose does that make sense and so
what we what do we have to do we have to
create the habits the routines the
patterns
where we learn to create and feel
meaningful moments it's i talk about
this in my book the motivation manifesto
or you guys hear me talk about on the
brendan show a lot my podcast
where you you have to take these moments
in time and do what i call slow time
it's like yes you're going to kiss your
honey on the way out the door to work
but you know what when you plant that
kiss plant that kiss baby
i like make it a moment feel that
moment you know when you hug the kids
and they run off to school like really
give a real hug
don't let pasaya and move on to the next
thing we're always moving on to the next
thing and not feeling
this moment we're not present in the
moment
because we're not thinking about let me
create something meaningful here let me
feel something here
because we're absent of presence
and the sense of meaning in the moment
we are disconnected from purpose
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35 is
not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following through
jump to 91 and when you commit publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps to 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen so
question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you
the deliver excellence rule this is
another prioritization
move for me it's like okay someone
throws some a big opportunity
to me it could lead to significant
growth i could get it going
but it compromises the delivery
excellence rule which is
wait if i take on these anything here
would that prevent me from delivering
what i
already promised the best that i could
like for me i'm very stretched in my
schedule i mean
very stretched i got to get a lot done
during the day
big team big brand been business big
clients
i gotta be man i gotta be good but
lots of great opportunities come my way
that could be significant growth this
year but then
the second level of that evaluative tool
is to say
huh if i do that though
will that steal away from something i
already promised to somebody
i care about or who's important to our
business
will that make me fail to deliver
what i wanted to deliver and so i got to
be honest
and i got to prioritize and i am like if
you saw how much
i work to prioritize things doesn't mean
i don't leave things i mean i'm sure my
team could tell you a hundred things i
haven't done that i
i'm supposed to or whatever so it
doesn't mean i'm perfect it just means i
work really hard at it
i'm very diligent focused on it because
i got people counting on me
i got you and i know you got people
counting on you too
so if something comes up and it's like
this great idea
but you're honestly it doesn't leave a
significant growth or you're not going
to start it
park it but also if it is
something that you could get going and
it would lead to significant growth but
it's going to screw up what you already
promised
don't break your integrity believe in
your ability
to figure things out i think that is the
ultimate belief
in life that you know what i believe
that i can figure out how things work
and i believe that i can get better
that fundamental structure in our mind
that says i believe
in those two things that i can figure
things out and i can get better
enables us for lifelong improvement and
growth but without them
good luck because if you take on a task
that you don't know how to do
you say well i don't know how to do that
so i quit
if you want to be like somebody who you
spot who you
see as a role model but you don't
believe in yourself you say i'm not like
that
so you quit so without belief as the
underlying element of your own mindset
there's no ability to grow there's no
ability to go anywhere
you have to look at this next stage of
your life and say
i believe i can figure it out if you
have a great dream
and you don't have any clue how to
figure it out you still go
i believe i can figure it out which
allows you to get up and get to work on
monday and start working towards it
if you don't believe you can figure it
out you don't have any
what psychology is called expectancy or
even
agency and so you won't begin the
journey but once you believe
that you can figure it out and you can
do it then you'll begin
so always believe in your ability to
figure things out
the power plant doesn't have energy it
generates energy
and i've been teaching that for like 15
years on stage and one guy stands up one
time he goes
actually you're wrong at my event you
know there's two thousand people in my
bed he goes well you're actually wrong
i'm like
oh i'm wrong he says well a power plant
doesn't generate energy what it does is
it
um takes energy from one source
upgrades it so transforms the energy
then stores it and transmits it so it's
really transforming energy from one
uh sort of location or one type of
energy to another
right and i love that metaphor because i
felt like that's my job
you know so much of my life is helping
people reach another level of energy
because if you don't reach an available
energy you can't serve at another level
if you don't reach another level energy
you can't feel better be happier be a
better spouse
you know it's like everyone says i want
that next level but they don't
understand
energy is the requirement to get there
and when we measured energy
in our studies it's we're talking about
really mental energy
emotional energy and physical energy and
it was a huge turning point in my life
when i started realizing these things
because
you know that whole thing that we as
entrepreneurs we want to wait
for maybe one day i'll feel energized or
maybe one day i'll feel joy
or maybe one day i can have fun after
you know all the money's in the bank
and you know you got you got the house
or the cars or the money or the
you know the stuff and then people go um
then i'm going to be really a fun person
it's like no if you're not a fun person
when you're broke you're not going to be
that much more fun when you're rich
and i think that people have to learn to
bring the joy
it's one of our little tag lines on our
shirt so i bring the joy
and that says you know you don't have
joy just like i don't think people
have happiness i don't think people have
sadness either i think that we are
generating
the emotions and the feelings that we
experience in life
and soon as we own that responsibility
life gets really fun
one of the major major keys we found the
first high performing habit
is seek clarity and what we found
is one of the practices that high
performers do
is they define the feeling they're after
and so when we had to explain that and
later
talk about it in the energy chapter we
had to differentiate between feelings
and emotions and they are different
emotions tend to be they're the same
like we have they're physical they're
almost always automatic even though when
the brain is creating associations
there's also happen
for us it's kind of emotion comes up
yeah you're watching a movie and you're
just sad and you're like oh my gosh you
know i'm crying
you didn't even have the tissues right
you're just like blah you know uh
but the feelings are usually
interpretations that we make of
what that emotion was and how it sticks
and the meaning we give it to it yeah
and the example i used
you know i like to give and i don't
remember if it's in the book or not
honestly because here's what's happened
this book is 400 pages it was
four hundred and eighty one when i
finished baby you edited it down yes and
it was one thousand four hundred eighty
one
good complete like it was like awesome
yes but i was like that's gonna freak
people out so we're publishing a bunch
in academic journals later and then
stripped it down to 400 pages so it's
more readable and fun and orientable so
i can't remember if this one actually
made it in there but
um the example i like to give is if you
and i go to
a haunted house yeah which i love i love
them
i love them and they scare me the crap
but if you and i walk around you know
you walk around on the walls in the
haunted house come jumps out at you yeah
you and i are both gonna jump
yes we are emotionally going to
experience fright
immediately it's gonna be there right
but i might be
freaked out for the next five minutes
and you might be laughing
why it's the meaning and the feeling
that we've defined it as
that's fine for everybody here's the
issue that people have and you have to
be careful about
when we start talking about energy
because emotional energy is real yes
and that is look if at six like we we go
to the haunted house at you know 5 p.m
in the afternoon
if at 9 00 pm now you're in your house
you're alone but you're completely safe
and you still
feel scared that's not the haunted
house's problem
that is the way that you are defining
and working through your own emotions
you had the emotion of terror and fear
and you're still
experiencing that feeling that's a
mental job
not an emotional job so your job is to
go wow
i'm at my house i i've lived here for 10
years i've never been threatened this
house this is a safe place
i got to redefine the feeling i want to
experience and i work with one
an olympic sprinter gold medalist
olympic sprinter
as a client and this person's huge
breakthrough in getting better and going
from literally
uh one olympics before not meddling at
all
to now gold i said what made like what
was the thing
yeah and one of the things they said to
me was i
learned to define the feeling and i said
what do you mean by that
and he basically said you know if if
if there's a bunch of us at the starting
box and we're all in perfect poise and
perfect condition
the one to bet on is the one that says
this is the way i want to feel in this
race right now
i know my emotions are going crazy like
my heart's beating i can hear
everybody i'm waiting for that shot
blast i can see my goal
i know how important this is and all
these like
their emotions are there yeah but that
person is defining the feeling going
i'm going to feel centered now
i'm going to get myself in the zone now
even though the anxiety is
the emotion of anxiety is there for all
olympic level
com competitors all of them but they
define that feat that emotion
as a feeling that helps give them a
performance edge
and i think that's important too you
know bruce springsteen says if he's ever
backstage
and doesn't feel like nerves he's gonna
hang it up
yeah but that's anxiety he's just
defining it differently
no matter where you are in accomplishing
your dreams or moving towards
the things that you really want in life
never let your
your small beginnings make you
small-minded
it's easy to say well that's impossible
and i know lots of people are telling
you that that's impossible you know many
people told me what i'm doing today is
impossible brendan you want to be a
writer
you can't write brenda you you want to
be a trainer you want to be a speaker
you want to do youtube videos you're not
good on video you're not this you're not
good at this
it's impossible oh you don't understand
how hard it is to make it brendan
it's so hard these days the stuff that
people tell me and i know have told
you is so nonsensical and based on so
many of their own
fears that have been unexplored
that it's sad and it can really cause
great people to stop
trying to do great things so i want to
encourage you no matter where you are
believe in yourself keep at it keep
working
keep going i mean success and
fulfillment are going to come from your
unflagging ability to believe
in what other people call impossible
it's going to come from your
unflagging ability to get up each day
and work towards things that maybe you
don't know where they're going
maybe they're not getting you what you
want right in the way maybe it's
not easy maybe it is a struggle but it
is through that struggle
and that effort and that dream and the
desire that you get there
but i tell people all the time there is
a difference between passion and
obsession
and high performers have obsession about
the topic
right they are obsessed about the topic
in which they're trying to
learn master grow into and so
that obsession is real i tell people the
difference here's how you know the
difference between the two
when you're passionate everybody cheers
you on
they're stoked for you oh you found your
passion awesome
follow your passion live with passion be
passionate
chase your passions everything like
passion passion passion passion passion
is good like the words will be like yay
right when you're obsessed they're like
why are you gonna be so crazy why can't
you be satisfied
why do you always gotta get things so
perfect why you spend so much time here
when you're obsessed people think you're
nuts so it's different
and it's like i always tell people if no
one thinks you're crazy
you're not yet operating to the outer
limits of your potential
you're not there yet because somebody in
your life should say
man you really care about this in like a
crazy way
and when you get there you know you
found your thing and not every find
nobody refines that
i think that's also why it's scary some
people go well
i'm passionate or i'm happy but i don't
really obsess about anything
you know most people obsess about you
know their shows on netflix more than
their life i know people who obsess more
about their
their you know thread count in their
sheets at their house
than they do about the impact they're
making in the world first way you should
not
compare yourself to others is in terms
of especially today
their fans their fame their followership
right their audience never do that in my
industry that's very very popular to do
and it's ruined a lot of people's lives
who don't
ever rise up to serve because they think
they're not popular enough
you know it's like that you write your
first book and you don't have as many
sales as other people and you think oh
well i don't have the audience
or you go to someone's fan page and you
see oh my gosh look at their
followership look at how many instagram
followers they have how many
twitter followers they have and and
because you see them so big you think oh
i could never be that
so you don't even begin and a lot of
people do that they say well i'm not
that big
so they never start but as i always say
you know what no matter how small you
start
start something that matters begin it
if i began my career looking at my
heroes looking at a wayne dyer or a tony
robbins or
marianne williamson a deepak chopra a
jim rohn
back in the day or or looking at people
like augmentinos who'd sold millions of
books or
or even the the famous books that you
saw millions and millions and millions
of copies if i gauged myself to that and
thought
that was the expectation i would never
begin
so you can't expect to start out with
tons of people some some people say to
me all the time well brendan it's so
easy for you because you got millions of
people on your email list and you have
millions of people on facebook and tens
of millions on youtube
i say it doesn't make it any harder for
me i still show up and shoot this video
and the reason i have the followers and
the fans and the audience
is because i showed up and i started
when there was only one dude 10 dudes
100 dudes
a thousand dudes watching us my first
seminar that i ever did
we only had 22 people in the room
and now we fill up seminars nine times a
year often from people from 46 countries
around the world
fly in paying thousands of dollars a
ticket and what did i do
i i started with 22 people in a room and
most of those people didn't even pay
and every time the the guy walked in
with with water i counted him as one of
those 22.
like i i had no followership it's never
about
how big you start it's that you start
and you get big
by staying at it because what people do
is they put out the first video they
write their first book they
they try their first thing online and
nobody follows nobody watches and they
quit
they get disappointed and where there's
disappointment
there was too high of as an expectation
on achievement
versus learning versus process versus
beginning
what you want to do is never be
disappointed and the way that you're
never disappointed is you understand
every single step counts every single
step is learning every single step gets
you going
creativity is not strongly correlated
with high performance
and if you told me that seven years ago
i would have fought with you for like
two or three hours
but then uh in one interview with one of
the world's largest uh ctos chief
technology officer he said brennan
you know they're they're a top 10 brand
in the world so we
we don't uh he said my team he said i'm
not creative
my team's not creative but we know how
to execute and scale
and execution and scale is really
important to long-term high performance
creativity might get you in the game but
a lot of people are creative but can't
work their way out of a bag
and i was like i would argue that
forever because i'm a crap a writer and
a coach
i would have never thought that you have
to actually show up every
day and inch yourself forward
toward these dreams and not only show up
every day and once in a while
inch yourself i mean every day you have
to actually take an
action that moves you forward not just
research not just
thinking look the power of an intention
is great but without any initiative it's
dead right a dream is great but without
any movement it's dead
you have to be moving towards every day
you can send an email every day
you can make a call every day you can
write something every day you can create
something every day you can contribute
something every day but it has to be
daily otherwise it will never become
actualized
the highest performers in the world
didn't get there because they were lucky
they
worked at it longer than everyone else
they had a better work ethic
and it's not that they necessarily
always worked harder they worked smarter
because they were doing
the research they were taking the time
to visualize how they would be distinct
different how they would survive the
tough times they really kept at it
keep every single day momentum
going and if you don't do that there's
no chance talk to any high performers
i'm sure you've interviewed
they kind of know the service and the
difference they want to make maybe not
precisely but they're asking the
question
so that's some of what we know they seek
clarity
um and that's kind of the first
practices
asking questions in those areas and the
other two real fastest uh
when you're seeking clarity they're more
clear about the feeling they want to
have
like an olympic sprinter who's won gold
is more likely to have said before he
went or she went on the track
how do i want to feel out there not like
just the result like
when i when the foot's in the block and
arms down like what do i want to feel
like they're very aware of the feeling
they're trying to get yeah i don't feel
nervous and stressed i want to feel
calm and yes clear and smooth and yes
and they're they're doing that self-talk
which is
seeking clarity and then the last one
which is really important they're
they're clear about what's meaningful to
them now
and what might be different in the
future which is something i didn't know
until we did a lot of the interviews or
the conversations is
uh a lot of people kind of know what i
like now they know what their passion is
it's like what's going to be meaningful
to you later like in five years
they've thought about that then you know
i would say they you know they've done
the work
so that's just the first habit and so
the book kind of opens with
with that story of like finding
what's we all have to decide who we are
and what we want
and how to get it at this stage of our
life
and when we don't know that you know
reaching high performance can be really
hard
yeah it's all about clear vision for me
it's the first chapter in my book is yes
the greatest leaders in the world have a
clear vision
love that yeah that's it and they got
that vision by seeking clarity yes that
was the habit that gave them the vision
they were consistently seeking like how
do i what do i
i mean they ask themselves more
questions that's one of our findings
they literally are doing more of the
self-talk asking more of the questions
which is so important so what's the
first social habit uh
increased productivity it's kind of like
no duh high performers are productive
dudes
um but what what the uniqueness is
they've they're not just pushing more
paper or checking more boxes
because you know i both know a lot of
people who you know
their busy work isn't their life's work
so they don't feel fulfilled from their
productivity high performers are
fulfilled from what they're
accomplishing
which is a big big big measure and
here's what they did they identified
their primary field of interest
which is a big deal then they identified
what we call pqo
prolific quality output which is what's
the outputs that matter and get
recognized and rewarded the most
in this primary field of interest and
then they went
all in at it they became almost singular
focuses like you know when
when jobs came back to apple and got rid
of all the product lines that these are
what we're doing
that was prolific quality output we're
going to be prolific quality output on
these things not those
so it's important like for me i thought
for
there was a period of my life where i
thought my primary field of interest was
personal development
and that's what most the world knows me
for i i've never posted any marketing on
my facebook
page in terms of like marketing advice
uh
i teach that that's way down in my
funnel
my front my youtube my podcast
facebook are all just personal
development so i really identified with
that
and then i launched my first book life's
golden ticket which was my life's
message
and it kind of bombed it had best seller
and then it died you know
bam wow yeah and uh really bummed me out
and i realized why i said you know what
i've been thinking my primary field of
interest
is personal development and so i folk i
did all the book i read all the books i
went to all the seminars i you know
studied with the gurus i became friends
with you know wayne dyer and tony
robbins the big names
that's what i thought it was and then i
had to make a shift
and i shift my primary field of interest
to
how to share a message
and it completely shift when i started
learning i was like you know what my
primary field of interest needs to be is
how to share a message because i already
got the message
all right and then i said well what's
prolific in this area well what's
prolific is
is what's recognized in this particular
area right at that time with this 2006-7
online video was just coming in i mean
youtube and facebook were young
youtube was like 2004 i think yeah 2005
or something
young and but what's mattering now is
video and i went all in
you know i've created 13 online courses
because in my primary field of interest
sharing
that personal development message was
everything so i learned how to share
everything
and i went from you know kind of a
busted
first book to an 18 months
4.6 million in revenue wow because i
learned how to sell
and i learned that sharing and selling a
message was just as important because
if you don't make the money you can't
sustain the message i had the message
but i wasn't making any money
i was the poor broke writer dude and i
was like so i shifted my
primary field of interest and i went i
got to understand marketing i got to
understand business
and what's going to be prolific in those
in what i'm doing now
and that's creating products to sell
oh i got to create more products higher
quality products i showed you like my
brochures and yeah beautiful stuff
just like super branding you know all my
books uh you know i
created i did all the covers of all my
books and i obsessed about i was like
the the look and the feel and stuff i
didn't care about before and
that changed everything so what i tell
people is if you want to increase don't
just get more stuff done
get more of the right stuff done and
really go in on it i mean
super obsessed about the quality and
really focus you know it's that old
saying
the main thing is keep is to keep the
main thing
the main thing exactly yeah oh you got
you very careful what your main thing is
great leaders envision a compelling and
different
and vibrant future than what is here
they have an alternative
clear view of what the world could be
like tomorrow than
it is today right they have a shared
purpose they believe that
they and others would be compelled by
interested
inspired by and want to work towards and
that's a big deal and you always read
about it in leadership right
you have to have vision i mean it's
biblical where there is no vision people
perish right we we know the power of
having that vision so
you have to sit down though and actually
do it the reason we say
envision versus just have a vision is
you have to sit
it's a practice of envisioning what
should tomorrow look like
for my team what should tomorrow be like
for my
business for my organization what should
tomorrow be like for my life
and not just tomorrow a long-term
mindset and view
the dream right that magnificent
obsession
that that bold desire the moonshot goals
and purposes
and missions of life the bigger picture
that's envisioning a different reality
in the future than we experience today
and that's what everybody gets excited
about in leadership
where there's no vision there's no
leadership where there's no vision
people
perish so you have to envision we always
have to continually sit down
and envision where are we where can we
be going it's an
active process if you set a vision one
time and and you forget about it
it's not going to help you accomplish
the influence or the impact you want
in your lifetime or in those that you
lead your life doesn't end up an
accident your life is a series of
actions that you initiate or donation
and that your thoughts are going to
control that roadmap
and so how are you using your mind today
to either make yourself feel great or
not i posted on
instagram this morning i said listen
your destiny is ultimately controlled
too
by a decision you already made this
morning everyone watching this
already made a decision this morning
this morning they made it
a life-changing huge decision this
morning and that
is either i'm going to get up
enter the world with no intention go
through the motions to hopefully get by
or survive
or i am going to get clear in this
morning
about what i want what i'm going after
who i'm going to be
how i'm going to serve and whether or
not i'm going to be excellent and
extraordinary
or not and the problem is most people
never make that conscious
decision so and so i was learning early
on
make the conscious decision about who
you want to be each day
stay congruent with that and that was
you know for me a kid who's just going
through the motions all of a sudden
going oh
who do i want to be what do i want my
relationships to be like that was really
important
you must define your mission
you need to have a mission for what
you're doing today you need to have an
intention
for what your next task is going to be
what happens most people just kind of
show up and they go okay well i guess
i'll
do some stuff but they have no intention
whatsoever
so they end up doing too many things
that mean nothing
towards their mission you should figure
out what is it you desire in life
and figure out the steps to get there
and start working a plan to get there
and minimizing
everything else getting very clear on
the mission
very clear on the mission and working
the plan
everything else guess what it gets a no
until you reach that mission or until
you're significantly on your way
that you have free resources to be able
to focus elsewhere
and that's what people do they take on
too many projects because they're not
clear about their
mission because i'm guessing if you're
watching this you know
you're somebody who wants to add value
and make a difference in the world so
anytime someone asks you to do something
yeah let me help you but
that might not have anything to do with
the quality of life
or the objective or the thing that
you're trying to achieve
or the service you're really intending
to offer right
and i know how hard it is because i'm so
pulled myself towards causes and towards
volunteerism towards helping so many
people
but guess what if i help everybody in
lots of different areas
i might not make my ultimate mission
of serving the people i want to serve
the most of making
my dreams come true so i could support
more people of running my business so i
can support
more people meaning it's easy to take
your eye off the ball
if you don't know what the ball is and
people often have never defined their
mission
and if you don't have one right now for
this day if you didn't have a
drive a mission a written down statement
about what you were going to accomplish
today
a checklist a goal sheet a time
management tool
that you filled out today and you're
just showing up today and going well i
guess i'll see what my inbox tells me to
do today
and you just respond to everybody else's
desires and everyone else's emails and
you're just
always in reaction always responding to
everybody
no proactivity towards a mission that
you defined yourself
you'll be lost you'll find
that because you never focused on that
one thing
or moving towards those several things
that were your priority
that you're just lost because and here's
another thing
focus goes out the window when we don't
have progress
right if we're not progressing towards
something our focus goes out the window
we just we just don't pay attention to
anything we don't feel good about
ourselves
you want to get more focus in your life
get more progress as you progress more
you start to get excited you start to
pay attention to things
that are working that are moving you
forward and you start to find more focus
in your life
i started setting personal challenges
every month at the beginning of each
month
i did this whole thing where i
holistically evaluate my life on the
first of every month
and it's like these 10 different
categories of my life you know from
emotional to relational to financial to
um you know career
mission objectives all these things i go
down that uh on the first month just
kind of a holistic viewpoint in my life
and then i set a personal challenge and
a professional challenge
and i do that every month every sunday
i revisit my progress every sunday for
23 years
so it's not like i'm just you know
one day ended up in a happy life it was
like that a level of self-evaluation
that most people avoid
until their birthday or new years i do
it every sunday and every first of the
month
and i don't ever miss my whole career
has been in some way or another a
struggle
against my own doubts all along the way
as much as people say gosh you're so
confident
you know you're that high performance
guy and everything else i'm like yeah
but it doesn't mean
i don't struggle matter of fact i
probably put myself in situations
where i must be challenged and i must
struggle more than
any normal sane person you know i'm
constantly pushing myself
all the time because i evaluate struggle
as something to be
honored you know it used to be struggle
a struggle was something that was
was truly honored by people they thought
that was something that built
character they thought that that was
something that was good and now we've
got to be such a convenient driven
society that's
into ease and so much to just i think an
unbelievable level of engage
i'm sorry entitlement where people don't
think they have to earn it and i'm
always like wait
you know if you have a dream never
forget if you knock on the door of
opportunity that it is work who answers
you know it takes a lot of work to
achieve your bigger dreams
to become the best you who you can be to
serve
more to create more to contribute at
that highest level man it's a lot of
work
if you're not doing block time here's
what your day might look like
you have all these different slots of
time right
and you're just going to plug in as you
go through the day
you're going to plug in oh i'll work
some there and i'll work some there
and then i'll try to cram stuff up right
at the end of the day i'll try to cram
that sucker in
any crammers crammers cameras cameras
okay just checking
no judgment no judgment you're just not
going as fast as you could
that's all crammers they're i love
crammers
yeah just like because they're easy to
get to move faster because you do have
that diligence
of when there's a deadline and it's on
you can go which
really serves you but we got to take you
from a crammer to a preparer to a high
performer
and the way that we do that is to look
at this and go
listen if you keep leaving all these
time slots to randomness
what happens
is they start to get filled
with the big d
distraction
[Applause]
some reason it seems like this hit home
for some people
i don't know why how many recognize what
i'm talking about here
so now you add up
take this out you might not be thinking
too seriously about it but let's say
that's like a day
one two three four five six seven eight
work hours
you didn't know i drew that on purpose
if you leave your time
to randomness you are stealing from your
greatness
if you leave your time to randomness you
are stealing from your greatness
bit by bit hour by eight hour day by day
week by week month by month
quarter by quarter year by year and
decade by decade and it's the little
things
like this where you're like oh my gosh i
didn't get
anything done because you've got all
these random approaches
to your day first enemy we all have is
doubt
you know we we doubt whether or not
we're capable we doubt whether or not
we're worthy we doubt whether or not
we'll succeed
we doubt whether or not we even deserve
it
and it's so unfortunate because i think
doubt is one of the greatest enemies of
our lives and
it's so easy to overcome but
most people won't practice the
discipline of overcoming it which is
weird right
they say oh i'm so doubtful and they
stop and it's like
if you have any negative recurring
emotion in your life doesn't maturity
require you to face it and say
hey how do i fix this you know
if you're always doubtful you can't just
wander around saying oh i'm so doubtful
like some kind of victim that's not fair
to the humanity you've been given that
that real power of free will that says
hey
you can direct your consciousness that's
why you have this big prefrontal cortex
other animals can't we can so handle it
if you've been plagued without your
whole life then face
it stop running from it i know that
sounds hard to say to people but i was i
had the same story
i was so doubtful that people would want
care about what i say
i was so doubtful that people would want
to read my books or listen to me at all
i was so
doubtful that i could chase my own
dreams and i realized for what reason
am i doubtful because of past failures
in the space no i'm trying something new
because uh people told me i might not be
able to do it so what makes them an
expert
on my capabilities and my potentialities
i thought well why am i so doubtful
we're doubtful because
the the germ of fear spread in our body
because somebody planted it there one
time or we cultivate it with our own
thoughts
and at some point maturity and
consciousness says
if doubt has been plaguing you let's
have a look at it and let's realize well
how do you banish it
well every single thing that we know
from spirituality
from philosophy from the great writers
and the great texts of
human culture has all revealed one thing
where there is doubt
grant me faith that we have to have
faith
and faith does not mean the absence of
doubt matter of fact the very definition
of
faith relies that doubt is still there
right
you can't have faith unless there's some
party that says well i'm gonna go anyway
despite the doubt so i'm not saying we
have to get rid of doubt forever
and handle it i'm saying doubt should
never prevent you from advancing
when you feel like advancing that in
your own mind you must say okay
i must trust in my abilities i must
trust that i will figure it out
i must trust that i can build it i must
trust that i can get some help
and progress even though the doubt might
be there look
the hero is a hero because the hero does
it anyway
right even though the hero's terrified
and risking it all
goes anyway and we're all heroes in some
way we can all be courageous
but i also think you know what society
overblows courage
society says you know courage has to be
some big magnificent act
but it's not i mean courage in this
world anymore is just
having the belief in yourself and having
the
the ability to genuinely express who you
are
if you're doubting yourself the only way
through
is to give yourself more faith and take
more action
and with more faith and more action
comes more competence
with more competence comes more
confidence in psychology they call it
the competence confidence loop
right the more you learn and try the
more you master and develop
so go out there even with that yes let
the doubt be there
but do it anyway why do you think people
can slip into
an obsession over netflix or whatever or
thread count
but they don't do that for something
that could really change their life
feedback that's interesting not what i
expected you to say what do you mean by
that
because you know
buying something or getting pulled into
netflix being obsessed about something
that gives you no feedback is not scary
a real obsession like trying to make an
impact in the world
you're getting feedback you're trying to
make a difference
in somebody's life they're going to tell
you that doesn't resonate with me
brendan
you try to make a difference in a
non-profit
you try to change the world you try to
start something like this
and the views come or they don't come
there's feedback and people are
terrified it's one of the four
central fears we all have is rejection
we're terrified like to be rejected and
think about if you really want to make
an impact
you're going to get a lot of judgment
you're going to get a lot of hate and
ultimately going to get rejection people
are going to like just dishonest people
are going to say that's not good enough
you're going to say who do you think you
are
and people are so worried about that
that they stop and so it's easier things
that don't give you feedback
watch the netflix don't give you no
feedback it's easy there's no
disappointment there even if you don't
like the show what do you do you just go
to the next show there's no
there's no disappointment there you know
i think trying to make an impact there's
a lot of disappointment and fear and
potential for rejection
so people don't get obsessed about
making a difference and making an impact
because it can hurt i need you to do
your work
before you respond to the world
it's the number one thing i'm always
telling people in high performance
academy
and all my other training sessions is if
you are constantly waking up in the
morning
and all you do is just reply to
everybody and reply to their text
you're replying to their needs you're
replying to their emails all of a sudden
the day is
ripped away and you find yourself out of
your own routine
but if you set up your morning to win or
you set up blocks of time to win
as we'll talk about and you do that
first
do your work first it's easier to say
discipline
if you're saying you know what this year
i want to uh in these next few months i
want to be more healthy
great get your health stuff out away in
the morning you know
create your shake do your workout create
a healthy lunch to take to work
and you're off and going to a good start
but if you
wait for the remainder of the day for
discipline to strike
it never will be more explicit in
communicating
your boundaries be more explicit in
communicating your time
so if you're going to meeting sit down
and say guys i have 45 minutes today for
this meeting
can't go a second over and like oh okay
and stop going over on your times if you
said you were gonna work out for an hour
work out for an hour
stop go a lot of the what i call bleed
time ends up taking away from our
balance
bleed time is those things where you're
you go over
on things that you didn't need to go
over on you know that that
one cocktail with your friend ended up
being in 16
you know and you lost the entire night
now or that one
you know lunch meeting you're gonna have
turned into four hours and now you've
lost the day of work
or that one show you were gonna watch
before getting back to work
turned into a whole season and you're
like oh no
the the the day the night is gone that's
called bleed time
it's where so much time just dissipates
because you didn't stick to your mark
so set your boundary communicate it
clear with people and don't go over on
things anymore
a lot of people if they just started
with the intention said we're only going
to do this for this much time and then
we got to go
if they stuck to that they would get
better balance
what we found in our research which
surprised me high performers do not
report working on their strengths
any more than regular people so that's
not what gives them the edge
uh one of the chapters opens up with
this guy he wrote this email really
highly successful guy
and he wrote this email me says you know
and i'd put him through all this i put
him through strengthsfinder
the berkman the colby the myers-briggs
everything this is one of my first
coaching clients ever i knew everything
about him
we knew all his background he did all
the we did all the homework had his peer
review you know his 360 success
from work and then i watched him fail
for two years and he wrote me this email
and he said brendan stop telling me like
what successful people
are like because
we know my strengths i'm not getting
ahead and start telling me what they do
and that's what this book came out it's
like what do you need to do
because and in this email he wrote this
which is where
that finding came from he said this was
so good listen this line
he said as a leader i have to be honest
with myself
that my mission and vision should never
be made to bow
down to my limited human strengths
i should have to rise up to my mission
or vision
the strengths aren't the relevant thing
is the question is
what is necessary for me to develop
into to reach that mission
it's like your strengths are great and
it's like yes of course do your
strengths but that's kind of like
what i tell people is like uh if
let's imagine you have a bear and that
bear wants to go on top of this cliff
over here
and it's never been on the cliff and he
wants to get that new honey up there
right telling the bear to focus on the
strengths to go somewhere that's never
gone before and do something that's
never done before
is stupid it's like saying hey you know
what just try being more of a bear
all right if i just you say brent i got
this big new vision i just say just try
being more of lewis
i mean it's a spiritual level that feels
good but you and i both know you're
going to develop
far beyond your comfort zones and
strengths
are typically comfort zones yeah we got
to overcome that and go next level and
develop new skills and overcome certain
fears and all these other things that
are going to help us get to the next
level yeah right
yeah yeah the whole conversation beyond
the comfort zone really requires us to
go beyond our strengths
i'm a writer i'm a coach and i'm a
trainer
my job is to share things that are
relevant to the teaching point
so it's what am i trying to teach now
i'll share case studies about my life
or some research uh but it's pretty
limited towards
only what i'm teaching and people sign
up for me to teach a very specific thing
so they're not seeing the whole picture
of my life they're just learning that
specific thing
so i think it also left a lot of people
going okay he's super successful but i
don't know anything about him right
right
and that created try to trust people you
don't know anything about yes
and or you read the motivation manifesto
right there is
no brendan in that book the publisher
turned
famously turned down the book we had a
two million dollar book deal
i turn in the book and the editor goes
what the hell is this
you wrote it like it's you know 1776.
you're not there's not one story of you
in here your audience wants to know
about you i'm like yeah but that's not
what i'm writing for
i'm writing for the art and so they
said we can't publish and we can't mark
this book is unmarketable so you wrote a
two million dollar check back
wrote it back which is painful because i
already spent it
um but then you went and sold a million
copies yeah then we went into
30 weeks uh 32 weeks on the new york
times best crazy seller list
after they turned it down with no
publisher well i guess you had like uh
yeah we went to a house
they supported it and distributed it did
a great job on it i love them and their
community really got behind the book
because
they knew i wrote it for the art not for
the i didn't sell out on the book it was
this was my artist my art has never been
like
talking about brendan my art has been i
want to teach but i want to teach in a
way that really hits you in the heart
and gives you habits you can implement
in your life
but that also took me out of the picture
a little bit
because i didn't want to be the guru i
didn't want to be you know i'm from
montana we're pretty private there
and one of our main sayings there is you
know the time to have the map
is before you enter the woods so i just
wanted to hand people the map
i didn't want to hand people like look
at me
i also had a big influence from my high
school journalism teacher
and she said there's two kinds of people
one who walks into room and goes here
i am and the other person walks into
room and goes
there you are
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there